today started out as the best day of my
life
back here tonight first shows at seven
yes
you know what that's gonna say joe
gardner
i did it i got the gig
welcome to your weekly ticket
paul thomas anderson's new movie has
cast cooper hoffman the late seymour
hoffman's son
this will mark his feature acting debut
playing a child actor in the 1970s set
coming of age drama
hoffman is playing the child actor at
the center of the film which involves
multiple story lines and is set in the
san fernando valley
the film will also star bradley cooper
and singer-songwriter alana heym
and according to collider uncut gems
co-director benny safty will also star
dear evan hansen the hit broadway
musical is coming to the big screen
the original show tells the story of an
awkward high schooler who gets caught up
in a lie after telling people he was
best friends with a fellow student who
dies by suicide
universal's adaptation has already
tapped ben platt to reprise the role of
evan hansen
in addition to platt julian moore amy
adams caitlyn dever and amandla stenberg
will star
stephen chabotsky will direct the
feature and steven levenson will write
the script
and stefan james from if beale street
could talk is set to star opposite
russell crowe
in paramount american son the film
centers on a man who after falling under
the control of a ruthless mobster while
in prison
builds a multi-racial crime syndicate
and earns a place for his crew
alongside rival mafias
it's no surprise there's been a ton to
keep up with as hollywood shifts release
dates due to coronavirus
but with movies like wonder woman 1984
and pixar's next movie
seoul there's still a ton to look
forward to this fall to break it all
down for us and give us a preview of
what's to come we have managing editor
eric
davis eric what are you looking forward
to coming out this fall
my most anticipated film believe it or
not
it's the next original movie from pixar
it's called
soul s-o-u-l directed by pete doctor and
for those who don't know the different
directors from pixar
pete doctor is the director that's gonna
probably make you cry
he's known for films like inside out and
up
and this is a film that stars jamie foxx
and tina fey
and i i like it for multiple reasons one
is pixar i love pixar i love everything
that they do
they're very creative and original and
colorful
and the animation always looks gorgeous
i'm also a big jazz fan i'm also a new
yorker this is a film that is about new
york it's about jazz it's about
music it speaks to everything that i
love in my own soul
and it's about a musician who's lost
passion for music and he's transported
out of his body
and he has to find a way back through
this infant soul
that's learning about herself so like
inside out it's gonna speak to emotions
emotions
souls are going to be characters there's
gonna be jazz
you know and jazz itself is eclectic
it's creative
it's original it's unexpected and i
think
jazz meeting pixar animation is just a
recipe that's
for awesome and so i think a lot of us
are looking for a good cry right now
after the year that we've all had i
think this movie will give it to us
yeah and usually with pixar it's a good
cry but it's it
presents hope so that's like a good
thing we need that a little bit of hope
too so i think that's
that's great what is everyone talking
about this fall well
you know superhero movies of course
marvel studios believe it or not but
their first
and only 2020 movie black widow
is due out this is a prequel about the
scarlett johansson character that's
gonna bring in
some characters from her past and we'll
see how it evolves the marvel cinematic
universe whether or not it speaks to
what happened to that character
uh and so we'll have to see sort of what
happens next with the marvel
cinematic universe and that is black
widow and then we also have
wonder woman 1984 this is a film that
has hopped around
to a few different dates but it looks
awesome and you know they very wisely
made the sequel to wonder woman
set in a completely different era this
is the 80s
there's going to be a pop of color it's
going to be funny there's going to be
fanny packs they figured out a way to
bring chris pine's character back which
is great
because the chemistry between he and gal
gadot is what makes that first movie so
special
kristen wiig plays a character named
cheetah she looks wild
so i think it's going to be a really fun
dc
sequel for uh wonder woman which really
was one of the most successful films
that dc has ever put out
so we have those two superhero movies
and then a couple of other big movies
that a lot of people are talking about
are candy man
this is nia de costa's film produced by
jordan peele it's sort of a spiritual
sequel
to the original candyman that's set in
the same neighborhood where
where the legend began and then of
course mr bond is back
he was coming back this past spring but
then cove it happened
so now he's coming back this november no
time to die
as it is being built as daniel craig's
final performance
as james bond we'll see
[Laughter]
but it's great oh there's a lot of like
really fun question marks behind
like all of the superhero movies coming
out you know because they're in
different time periods
kristen wiig what do you think are you
excited about that i am i
watched that last trailer where at the
end of it we see a little bit of her
final transformation into cheetah
and it looked pretty interesting so you
know i'm curious to learn more about
those characters and how the villains
factor in and
does it set up anything else are there
any other dc characters that we see you
know
dc fandom was such a big event so many
things were revealed there
uh what will wonder woman 1984 set up if
anything
of what we are still to come to see from
the dc
extended universe yeah exactly i didn't
even think about that it has to
potentially set everything up or be its
own little spin-off
but what about stuff you know under the
radar we know that everything's moving
but is there anything that's going under
the radar that may be an
oscar contender yeah potentially i'll
give you a few that i'm looking forward
to
and i'll start with a film called one
night in miami and i start there because
regina king
who has just been lightened up the joint
as of late
winning an oscar to winning an emmy
nominated for more emmys for watchmen
this is going to be her future
directorial debut
takes place february 25th 1964
to be exact cassius clay uh just
defeated sonny list and he became the
heavyweight champion of the world
he wants to go out and celebrate he
can't go out to miami beach because
the jim crow era segregation laws are
still in place and so he has to go
to miami's african-american overtown
neighborhood to hang out with some of
his best friends who are his best
friends
malcolm x jim brown stan cook so this is
going to be
a pretty awesome movie uh from regina
king telling this story
that we've never really seen before on
screen played out
so that's one movie that i would highly
recommend also
on the rocks is another one this is
sophia coppola's new movie
why everybody's talking about it is
because sofia coppola
is re-teaming with bill murray you'll
remember they made lost in translation
bill murray was paired up with scarlett
johansson in that film in this film
he is paired up with rashida jones and
rashida jones plays a
a woman who's married to a guy who's
traveling away
on business a lot she feels like he may
be up just something
uh so she goes on on it all night kind
of to track him and follow him and see
what's going on
uh and she takes her playboy father with
her bill murray
they're a bit estranged and trying to
reconnect and so looks like a really fun
role for bill murray
rashida jones is really great too and so
seeing that match up from sophia coppola
is one to watch out for another couple
that i'll give you spontaneous
if you're looking for a high school
comedy that is thinking
really outside the box this is based on
a novel about a high school where the
kids just began spontaneously exploding
uh out of nowhere so and everybody
i mean i'm not laughing like that sucks
it's just funny
i think it's played as like a dark dry
comedy
okay of these kids that are just
exploding and it's like what the hell is
going on
catherine langford charlie plummer are
among the stars in that one
and it just looks ridiculous and it i i
think for somebody that's just
wanting to look for like a high school
common dark comedy that's just different
they're spontaneous and then lastly uh
there's a film called
i'll just say the name it's called [ __ ]
house um and
it why i mentioned this one this is a
really small one but it did
win the grand jury prize at the virtual
south by southwest film festival that
just took place
this past spring i was able to watch it
and if you're a fan of films like before
sunrise
you know sort of these movies about
people meeting and then spending like an
all night together where they're
learning about each other's past and
they're learning about
each other's futures and will they fall
in love will they not fall in love
are they meant to be together those sort
of movies for a romantic
this is this one it's written and
directed and starring a guy named cooper
rafe
as well as dylan uh galula who is all
fantastic in it
uh and it's about a college freshman who
goes to a party at this frat house
that's named [ __ ]
and ends up spending the night this
sophomore uh resident advisor
and they just kind of hang out all night
she's going through some stuff he's
going through some stuff
together maybe they can figure out what
they want to do next and it's a really
sweet movie and like i said
i talk about richard lynch letters
before sunrise because it feels very
much inspired
by that film but for a new generation
thanks for the recommendations i i don't
think i knew
about a couple of these all right well
thank you so much eric davis managing
editor at fandango
love having you on the show man
in theaters this friday is broken hearts
gallery
lucy do you think you want to try
getting out of bed today
we're getting smell complaints from the
city have you just been masturbating and
braiding your hair for three weeks
my vibrator will never break my heart
well it will break your vagina
broken hearts gallery follows the always
unique lucy a 20-something art gallery
assistant living in new york city
who also happens to be an emotional
hoarder after she gets dumped by her
latest boyfriend lucy is inspired to
create the broken heart gallery
a pop-up space for the items love has
left behind
word of the gallery spreads encouraging
a movement and a fresh start for all the
romantics out there
including lucy herself geraldine
viswanathan daycare montgomery and
bernadette peters star
but if you'd rather stay in check out
beats on fandango now
they want us to get in line but we won't
they want us to be afraid of each other
but we're not
that boy drag you down just you try
and stop us all
a universal story of friendship
rebellion and the irresistible power of
music set against the backdrop of the
criminal justice and public order act of
1994
which banned unlicensed raves across the
uk
beats follows best friends and polar
opposites jono and spaner
who realizing they are destined for
different futures sneak out to an
illegal party in pursuit of one last
crazy night together
all right everyone well that's it for
today but leave us a comment and let us
know which fall film release you're most
looking forward to
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
you